There were like sanchez you said they
were just humans here shining shoes now
parish. We put them on worked and although
i wasn't slippery. When they were wet.
No they weren't slippery she
had weren't slippery with
especial work boots or were they just like
statues. You know really after strattera
shanshu. But there were birds. There
you know there were. There was no
clothing supplies you had to buy me so hard
to shower. Did you ever have to have to
work inside the cord high or rate and shed
a quarter when they were no durant had
to do hold your aunt at top shade
for i understand most much
and very well can show up
when i caught him most. But the splice
played between all the way down the cover
plate you had to do that all the way through
why we had to read it. But it was and
you say it wasn't it was built it. Yes it
was too harsh for fear of it left us and
put an efficient. Then course
section. We've heard and
yet another section. We've put in and
i'm afraid you are finished. First
you finish in work. You had to do
a thing to to george.
On the inside when you when you were
riveting hand or do you were never
a big i really have and i mean inside with
you wherever you know chad. Giving any
any scale hot scale going on. Do you
prevent. Most of would not like you show
us that your section here
was and we weren't on the
nevers she was such an underneath. Just
gotta get tough on the outside. Oh i see
someone i'm with you but if you get any
scale coming off the rivets i'm here. Oh
yes. We had to we had to wear long
duck and share it went right out on
the on each stage to stop iran's were
killed when i took off after
it would drop on them.
We had to be pretty cause they wouldn't get
in down in your boots as well. Ever. No
never got to go near very much.
I think you get more doing
a very clean workshop and the holder might
get more as well from the inside as well
but need some time when you know he was
going to leave it here on and shows
kneeling down. But he's rich. You need not
have to do is put even if you know i'm
connected with ford. And had a rattler and
a piece of pipe to hold it hold the machine
up on the other side that it held it up
so machine. It just had
a hole not machine and
i put it on not of it
and pressure at the top card phone cord
and down. Did you get it that the that
this didn't change just by piece to
something like that it would
skate and i always had
a stroke honest monish hope. On
a piece of paper. So that it was up
against he had had at the pope should
understand but
a pope should fluff. Just
very wander and use the
automatic passport as the pneumatic tubes
for the rivets the new did you start
using those pneumatic tubes to pass the
rivets sound from the from the cooker to
the catcher. We have just dropped and don't
share. And on that you were on the top
cause a did they have oil or
a coke furnaces or it was on no
bigger sack universe and are cooked far
more for insignia and how heavy
with the biggest rivets. Oh
yeah i did some seven eight
something like that with
a i got it. You have net
evidence or you in the bottom of
course there's a heavy
ones a real big one. Yes
a very good. Cord from your insurance
years. Yeah yeah. Do you see any any
interesting things from up the top of the cord
that you have that you can. You know
you manage johnson coming over. If you
ever amy johnson coming over the bridge
flying over our right we're going to hear
flynn plan or did you. Waiter. Oh.
Would we have she she
shares you're not we have
to hire you ever. Somebody
tell me about seeing
a whale down shark. If i shot
big shark. But if i feared
a daughter like mad why take
cloture nor show dare to show
. It near shade from the nose. We were on
a nice and now voyage. So then refreshed
and had no idea the shark
was nothing happened
and some of the boys used to dive
in and swim there ever fell out
on
a shoe thing missing fish
placidly floating along
a very very painful from
where we were out we were on
a bridge. Like. What could be
a very big shark. Do you have it if
you've got did you get your canberra
to pump it for working on the on the chance
to do you get what did you get anything
from mr. Freeman for. When they're
asked joined you know i didn't get
a shunt from you didn't get the two shilling
piece which i was told they were that
mr.
Freeman gave that's the the engineer who who
worked on the design of the bridge consulting
engineer. Yes he did give
a canberra two shilling piece to everybody
that was working on there yes you got to
. He went to syria and to bob which you
know you did get that. Yes i got tried
and true i know that when you when you
finished up when did you finish there.
Oh i buy what you what that
means no just be better off
when no more recorder. Nothing and
what happened to you then cut
a corner look for work you know if
you find one. Yes i'll probably get
one don't know what track you went on the
dole. You know you know under the news
you that you got
a job and i don't care where
did you live in new zealand.
Oh i lived in an hutch. You
know tried on the job.
Where abouts was it. What what time
is it near it. You know was it
a bridge or what was it working on
i didn't know shop right or shop
was it auckland or wellington or. We're
willing to know or oakland. Opened.
When you're open and were
worried. Well again. I
think it turned shipment.
We went to one five. From
auckland
a long time ago and what sort of
work was that. Oh i wouldn't buy
for just
a room for it and riveting paint
was it riveting. No wonder and
i don't know but there were like you
know oxy or something. You know
and well you know you've done that before
you came to australia. Oh. I really like
it but not not can show
a common interest. Sure you did it
and belfast. You know i think that's
a didn't do any and i think well and
verify that it hadn't started and i
was more inclined to reardon
and verify. And i'm here now
and later on you did up welding
did you know here i picked up
electric welling and
up she was telling and
. You never got training just did you know
right. You never got any training and if
you just did it. Never you never got it.
I just picked it up you want through.
Where did you work when you came
back to australia. I mean we have
a new zealand you know i'll show you why.
Show them what i mean you can your castle
there. Yeah. What was that shipbuilding
ship building was that riveting or was it
welty you know it was
a man and how long we are it
was hard. I suppose drug that
sharon evert if you didn't was. So
bizarre to lot of the war. Oh yes
right. And then when you came you know it
was full of war for your drug. And don't
you try commotion here. Yes but on the
bridge fell and i know you know what they
did trying to five. I work you know
my friend and i said yes. Then
i come to sydney. Now i was
thrown long at it and i
jumped out and i left on there. Then after
that you were on the bridge and now i
come down to bridge. On the bridge and then
you would have to new zealand. I don't
usually do where and what it called
from where were you when the bridge was
opened. Where were you when the bridge was
open in seventy. So that's only thirty
two. Yeah since then they won't need you
to ride and you say to tell. How long
i devote to you two years and usually an
organ for you know me and then when the war
started. You come back here are we back
here before the war. I've back here for
the second world war. You know and
i yes i came back here for your.
And then when you. Where did you work
back at wash island after that you know i
didn't work when i come back from you. You
know now from new zealand. I come back
and charge. Have been on the
pension. Ever since i got it.
Did you get. To get compensation
for a fair hearing. I got
a $13 from i hear what i
want and tried to poke
my hearing to get cured if possible.
You know deafness is rare.
No huge. And with dr.
Jeffrey i should. Somewhere
else. I don't know
shop in sydney hospital he chariot
. Along with a bridge of four to get
a constitution was that. You know
that i can tell you just
yeah it was because when we
working during the second
world war. You remember
. You know i thought you
were retired but yes.
I was
a pope and now by and you
know i should be when
that was started and one hundred ninety
two thirty nine. You know you'd only be
thirty nine when you know harry
lauder came out to shanley and
i ran
a fake band known for it. Yeah it and should
be sure and where we work you know we
were then. I've already made you sick as
the beginning of the second world war is
ninety thirty nine you were born in one
hundred twenty. No one right way so you
don't even thirty eight at the beginning
of the first world war second world war.
So you know you would have been retired
by then would you know the triad then you
musta been working
somewhere. I tell it opera.
Where you don't you don't remember where
you were where you worked after that. Do
you hold more track. Yet you know you
did work at more most ok. Oh yeah in
a war it was more do you remember. Remember
any union activity over there you were
the boilermakers you know you member of any
of the union activity during the war my
stock. You know our cockatoo
actually yeah. Our overhead.
Had you terry. We get
you more to watch her
you need to get involved in that
now and. When you left more
still you got you went to cockatoo did you
know i don't look. To the gasworks at
mortlake yes you know we working on the gas
side as and things like about you know
organ. Negara not yet what repairing them
the. The retorts. Yes it was
a maintenance job. Was it maintenance
or building. Maybe you know
was that. How was that compared to
the average travel mortgage at gash.
Wasn't very competitive very quiet
harvard. We have good you know
well. You remember where you went to work
after the gap gets worse. You remember
that. Now you know it was
a gas auction long time. Jumper tom
evans over there in fact. Yes.
In fact i think that after left
a catwalk. How do you knew you
know. It was tom evans at the
gasworks when you were there was
he. No you wouldn't dare he was
a trigger on the heart of ridge. Yes you
everyone. How would receive. I don't
remember her on
a very he said i think
well. Thank you very much.
We'll leave it there. You know.